At this special dinner organized by a company called Opaque, there's a lot more to your meal than meets the eye.
It's a three to five-course dinner in a completely pitch black dining room setting,...
...so it's really an experience to enhance your many senses...
...and take you on a journey unlike any other dining experience you've ever had.
Diners are completely in the dark, literally.
You can't see where you're going or what you're about to eat.
I'm trying to figure out where I am and how big the room is and who else is in there and what I'm smelling,...
...and it's so different than what you're used to.
Diners are guided through the experience by servers who are the best possible beacons for the journey.
I'm gonna lean on the corner of the table, okay?
Okay.
And here, here's some bread, that's for you.
Okay, I'm on the...
...I'm not, I have my hand.
No, you're not. Here, on this side. There you go.
Okay.
They are all visually impaired themselves and have to find their way in the dark on a daily basis.
That's part of the point.
The food on your plate is also food for thought.
Coming into the diner over an hour and a half to two hours gives them a whole different take.
They're operating in a world where we have the advantage.
We can see and walk on, and all of a sudden, they have the advantage because they can navigate fine.
Actually you're like, "Oh my god, I'd never be able to even function for a second."...